Okay, welcome to our first Zoom call that we're doing for Lucicel Tower.
And I'm going to pull up the questions that we had to get started with those.
Quite a few come in, so let's get started.
Okay, all right.
The first question is, I recently had a screened mammogram
and they want me to come back for a diagnostic mammogram,
and possibly an ultrasound.
So usually if you have a screening mammogram that they found some lesions,
so what an oncologist or a radiologist uses the term lesions,
whether they're looking at an X-ray or a mammogram or a CT scan or an MRI,
they'll use the word lesions to say that there's something going on that they saw abnormal on the scan.
That doesn't mean a lesion like you think it has to be a tumor or something like that.
But there's something abnormal there.
Certainly could be a tumor, could be cancer, but it suggests that we need to investigate a little bit deeper.
That they may want to do a deeper diagnostic ultrasound,
and there's some new type of 3D ultrasounds, depending on where you're going,
or 3D mammograms, depending on where you're going that could get a better picture.
There's some brand new technology out that not very many places have,
that it's a totally different type of mammogram, which is actually pretty neat and excited for that to come on the market.
And then an ultrasound, and then from there if they still see that this mass is suspicious,
they may request to do an ultrasound guided biopsy.
So that's kind of the progression with breast issues,
and that's fairly normal.
Now if you ultimately do want to find out whether it's a cyst or it's a cancer,
you have to get a biopsy.
So the only way to know that you absolutely know whether it's cancered on
is to get a pathology report.
You could only do that through a biopsy.
From a medical legal standpoint, you have to have a biopsy in order to have a diagnosis.
So in order to have a cancer diagnosis, it has to be done via pathology report via biopsy.
So this person goes on to ask about whether they can do a thermography.
Is that helpful?
So thermography is very helpful to see if there is metabolic activity,
because thermography is going to pick up heat,
and you're going to have an increase in metabolic heat if there's an increase in metabolic activity.
So that can be very helpful, but if thermography is not going to be diagnostic of cancer,
nor is it diagnostic that there's not cancer if the thermography is within normal limits.
So a thermography is a screening tool, and you have to understand that.
So you wouldn't say, okay, I don't want to do a biopsy.
Can I just use a do thermography?
No. If you're free biopography,
and you said, I don't want to do a mammography, I want to just do thermography,
then I would say, yeah, you can make those kind of decisions, those healthcare decisions.
You don't want to do mammography because they are radiation.
And use thermography as your screening tool,
and then from that screening tool, go and do more comprehensive diagnostic tests like ultrasounds
and or further on with biopsies if the thermography was positive.
All right.
Hi, Dr. Cutters. I was wondering what is the best protocol for parasites?
I have all the symptoms.
I feel very out of whack as well.
So first of all, you want to test.
So you want to do some sort of diagnostic.
So if you have all the symptoms of parasites,
there are a lot of symptoms that would be listed on a website as these are symptoms of parasites.
It can be symptoms of other things as well.
So I wouldn't trust that.
Now, if you didn't see if you did pass a parasite,
and you know that you know that you know that's a parasite,
lots of people say I passed these things.
I know they're parasites.
And if they take a picture of them or they bring them into a lab, they're not parasites.
So you could pass things in your stool that look parasitic in nature,
but they're not parasites can be something you ate can be, you know,
other things that you digested improperly.
Maybe you have improper digestion of things.
So you want to get a diagnostic test.
Now, there are comprehensive stool sample tests.
We have that in our Rupa lab.
So if you're a member of one of our courses,
you could order a comprehensive stool sample test.
That's the most comprehensive, hence the name,
test to test for parasites in your stool.
So you're going to have parasites elsewhere.
Don't always have intestinal parasites.
You can have liver flukes.
You can have parasites that go systemic.
Then it's more difficult to test for those things.
Do you eat a cheek swab type in etiology?
Type test is probably a more appropriate test for those things.
However, there really isn't any big harm or foul to treat.
As if you have parasites.
You know, you're making your own health care decisions here.
Do I have to go and spend the money on the test?
I just treat that instead.
Well, you certainly can.
The product that we recommend is the product that we private labels.
Prior to us, private label eat it,
we recommended that product all the time for a long time,
probably a decade.
That's our product that we private label as para clear,
hence parasite clearing parasites.
It comes in a large bottle.
I think there's 240 capsules per bottle or something like that.
And you dose it based upon your weight.
So if you have a child that's maybe six years old and only weighs 50 pounds,
you'd only maybe give them one a day.
If you have an adult that weighs 150 pounds, you maybe take three a day.
Or if you feel like you want to just cleanse yourself out as an adult,
you could take more.
I've had people take up to nine to 12 a day for a very short period of time.
And then they drop it down just to kind of cleanse themself,
especially if they just got some sort of food poisoning or something like that.
Now, remember with intestinal parasites,
you want to also dig to the reason why because you might have a climate in your intestinal track
that is prone to allowing parasites to grow and or primarily expose your parasites.
So where do you get parasites from?
Well, you get parasites from your diet primarily.
So eating foods that are infected with parasites,
things like sushi, probably the most common thing that you think of.
But even with that, if you ingest a parasite, you really,
you still shouldn't get parasites.
You should quite honestly, if you have proper HCl production in your stomach,
you should be able to eat parasites and not get parasites.
Because if you have proper HCl in your stomach,
that should be, you should have a pH of about 1.5 in the stomach itself.
There, there's no parasites that will live beyond that.
So you will have killed everything.
You can go eat sushi that's laden with parasites.
And if you have proper HCl balance in your stomach,
you won't get intestinal parasites.
So henceforth, you know, consuming, adding HCl to your diet,
taking HCl with your food to make sure that you have proper HCl production.
And there's, I have a whole bunch more information on that.
HCl, helicobacter pylori, which technically I said the parasite
is a bacterial infection, but it's parasitic to your body in a sense
that it causes so much ill health in your gut and in your arteries.
Look at those blog posts.
Because go to our website and search HCl or digest it,
or Hpylori, you'll get to a blog post that kind of walks you through the reason why.
And I've created some really nice videos of why you should be taking HCl.
And why the worst that you can do is trying to,
quote unquote, alkalize your system by taking baking soda or alkalized water.
So I go into, you know, you know, maybe more depth than I need to.
In that category, because it's so important.
So, you know, parasites are, you know, I blog to Facebook again.
For a period of time, I was off Facebook completely.
I jumped on Facebook again, because I like these groups.
I'm in a candy group and a soup group and a gardening group.
And some of these things that I like it.
But I do come across the feed and there's a lot of misinformation in the feed,
which I'm astonished. There's a practicing natural doctors or practicing natural people
that are pathic chiropractors or something.
Sometimes giving very wrong advice.
And one of the most ill advised things out there is about alkalizing your body
by taking alcohol, drinking alkalize water using baking soda in, you know,
adding that to water, drinking that things like that to alkalize your urine
and alkalize your saliva, then selling pH strips to test your urine and test your saliva.
I have some blog posts that are more information on that.
But if you want to get parasites, then do that.
I mean, by all means, follow their advice if you like parasites.
Because that's how you're going to get parasites.
If you alkalize your stomach, if you raise the pH of your stomach
beyond a highly acidic environment, meaning once your pH of your stomach gets to 2.0, 2.5,
3.0, that's still acidic.
But the more alkaline it becomes, the more of an environment that you've created to get parasites.
Because there are parasitic spores, probably even on organic food inventables,
and you're going to end up with parasites if you have an alkaline environment in your stomach.
So you need a very acidic stomach in order to protect yourself from parasitic infection.
But if you think you have parasites, never want to look at the environment,
make sure that you are taking HClzyme or our product.
That HClzyme is one of our products.
But one of the products that I like best is our private label, Clear Digest,
because it not only has HCl, but it also has Digestive enzymes.
Plus, it has bile support, which a lot of people need.
So anybody over 35 needs bile support.
And just to help support your gallbladder and your phase 4 detoxification pathways.
So taking Clear Digest 2 or 3 or more per meal is going to help alkalize your stomach,
help you with digestion, help prevent parasitic infection,
both bile support and bile secretions for fat digestion and help with that environment.
Taking some probiotics can help with the environment of your gut,
and certainly using a product like ParaClear can be good to help bring that to balance.
I would suggest that even when you're taking a parasite killing protocol,
of any kind, most of them have TH1 stimulator.
So no, you should know if you have an autoimmune disorder or not.
Because if you have an autoimmune disorder, you have to be careful on how long you take those TH1 stimulants,
because it can actually make your autoimmune disease worse.
And one of the ways you know is if you take TH1 stimulants in parasite products,
because they're going to have garlic in them, they're going to have oregano oil,
they're going to have things that are going to be an immune stimulant.
Or if you take vitamin C and things and you feel worse when you take it,
that's maybe not worse with your gut, maybe it's going to actually help your gut,
but it's going to flare your joints, your joint pain,
or layer your exhaustion because of maybe you have antibodies to the thyroid.
So you're going to have more fatigue.
Or what other, maybe you're going to have more brain fog,
or you're going to, any thing, any time you stimulate and immune your immune response,
and you have antibodies to self-tissue, you will do more destruction to that self-tissue
when you stimulate that immune response.
So that is without doing an antibody test, like a Cyrex array 5 or array 7x test,
without doing that test and having a, you know, getting a proper diagnosis that you have an autoimmune disease,
if you stimulated your immune system and your symptoms,
any symptoms in your body got worse by stimulated your immune system,
it's pretty good indication that you probably have self-antibodies.
So that would spark you to get that test. I see that in the Lyme community all the time.
People think that they have chronic Lyme meeting in their definition,
they have a continued infection.
So they still have an acute infection five years post-exposure to Burelia bacteria,
and they are constantly in the killing mode that they have to be killing this,
you know, I have this Lyme flare, I have to be killing it so they're taking, you know, cat's claw
and vitamin C protocols, and regardless protocols, all these immune stimulated protocols,
and it makes things worse.
But they think that they're just getting a Herk Simon reaction,
and it's good, they're getting dios, so that's good, I must be killing it.
Well, actually they're just stimulating an immune response that's destroying self-tissue even more so.
So I'll make sure you look at our autoimmune course to get more details on that.
I have a bunch of videos on the blog about autoimmune disease,
and you don't want to be flaring in an autoimmune response.
I'm going to have to keep this call a little short. I have a really bad cold.
Even though I'm sunburned, so I know this is so red, so we got back from Florida,
but it wasn't so super warm down there, and trying to be out on the beach,
and destined, and it was freezing in some of those days, and I ended up at the worst cold.
Okay, another question.
What supplements would you recommend a woman in their 40s?
Low energy, I have ordered many supplements, but I'm guessing,
which I take them with food.
If I don't take them with food, okay, even when I take them with food, I feel nauseous,
so I take them with many different times.
Also, oh well, thank you very much.
Okay, so what supplements should you take woman over their 40s? Low energy.
Really?
So in general, so in general, what supplements should a person take when they get to be over 40?
You really, what a supplement is is you're supplementing your diet.
First, I could look at making sure you're getting your nutrients through your food
is the best way to go.
Oh, well, I can't get all my nutrients through my food.
I'm busy, I'm not eating as well as I know I should be eating.
Well, then taking a multiple vitamin would be a good thing to take in most people's minds.
And most for most, for a lot of people, that would be just fine.
The problem is most multiple vitamins are synthetic, so they can actually do more harm than good.
So I like whole food things as much as possible.
So in general, taking like our greens first product would probably be a better whole food supplement
as far as getting your nutrients go.
But I have to take a couple of steps back to answer this question.
Really, you want to figure out what's going on?
So if I have low energy, you always have to get back to asking that one simple little question.
Why? Why? Why? Why do I have low energy?
It's because I have low thyroid. Do I have low energy?
Because I have low adrenal glands, do I have low energy?
Because my pituitary gland, do I have low energy?
Because I have low sensitivity, do I have low energy?
Because I am an autoimmune issue that I'm not even addressing, do I have low energy?
Because I have toxicity issues, sluggish gallbladder can cause low energy.
I mean, the list is literally endless.
So getting some diagnostic work up to me is always best.
Otherwise, you're just throwing darts at the law.
So figure out the reason why.
And then you start treating that diagnosis or some set of diagnoses to try to clear out that person
to see what's best for them.
So in general, if a person says what's a good multivitamin to take,
I'm really healthy.
But I want to stay healthy that I would say like a greens whole food greens product.
We have a private labeled predatal vitamin.
But I regret private labeled as a predatal because it's a whole food.
It's the only whole food predatal vitamin I think on the market.
So it's a great multivitamin, but it's a whole food multivitamin not just for women carried baby.
So if you're like, I can't take greens.
So I actually have greens in capsules also.
But if you want a vitamin, that's a whole food vitamin.
It would be our predatal complete.
That's not a private labeled product.
But as far as giving symptoms like a hablo energy of trying to figure this out,
we really need to, we need to dig into this a little bit.
So whoever asked this question really schedule a case review with me.
And then we can dig into why you have these issues because when you say what I take.
All my vitamins, even with food, I feel nauseous.
There's something going on.
It could very well be as simple as just an HCl deficiency and take into HCl with your food might be the issue.
But it could be even, it could be much something much more complex.
You could actually have antibodies to college and you can have antibodies to what they,
what they make even natural supplement capsules out of.
And people can feel worse when they take supplements because they have antibodies to that gelatin stuff.
So, you got to kind of dig into this to figure this out.
Sometimes our answers aren't as easy as that.
All right.
This next question is referring to the right machine.
I assume it says will this machine.
I think they're talking about the right machine.
Help a delay or reduce the progression of Parkinson's disease.
So, again, even with Parkinson's disease, it's not a matter of, oh, I'm just one therapeutic tool away from making some big difference in that.
You got to dig into the Parkinson's disease is destruction of this part of the midbrain way deep inside the brain part of the archaeo cortex.
That, that makes dopamine.
So, you have almost always with Parkinson's disease, you have antibodies to the substantiate digger.
The substantiate digger has the name of that deep seated nucleus.
That's called a nucleus where all these nerves gather in the deep part of the brain that makes dopamine.
So, when you have antibodies to that, it breaks that down and you don't make dopamine.
That's what really what Parkinson's disease is.
So, these people are put on aldopa and which is a synthetic dopamine.
That tends to work help greatly for a period of time.
And then it tends to start to fail and it doesn't work as well.
It has to do with the receptors and the brain aren't as responsive to the synthetic dopamine.
They have to increase the dosage and it just doesn't tend to work as well anymore.
Now, there are some new drugs on the market that can be beneficial, but there's still none of them are addressing the cause.
So, with Parkinson's disease, the first thing we want to do is run antibody tests.
You absolutely have to do that.
The thing that's missed with all autoimmune disease, the thing that's missed by most doctors,
is that when you have self antibodies and you're not addressing the triggers that you might have from foods, from molds, from pesticides, from chemicals,
because you can have antibodies to those things too.
Then when you're exposed to foods or exposed to that chemical or exposed to that mold,
you'll fire an antibody in immune reaction and you'll destroy any time again.
You fire an immune reaction.
You'll destroy what you have antibodies too that are already circulating in your body.
So, if I have antibodies to my substantiate today, you're already because I have Parkinson's disease.
And I also, let's keep it simple, let's say I do an antibody food test and let's say it's dairy.
Let's say I have antibodies to casene, which is the protein and dairy.
So, and I eat dairy, well, I'm going to fire this immune response.
So, it's going to fire up this immune response and I will kill that which I have antibodies against first.
So, can I kill dairy? No, it's not a living thing.
But it's going to cause an inflammatory response around that and I could end up with a gut pain.
That's why people who have dairy sensitivities because they have antibodies to casene can end up with diarrhea, got paid.
Or, and or they'll get inflammation elsewhere in the body.
They could enjoy pain, they could get all sorts of different things.
But if I have self antibodies, in the case of Parkinson's to the substantiate diagram,
I'm going to do more destruction of that and I'm going to have worse Parkinson's symptoms.
Also, with dairy and gluten it even gets worse and more complicated because you have casio morphine receptors in the gut and the brain and gluteumorphine receptors in the gut and the brain.
So, if you have antibodies to gluten or the gluten antibodies or casene, you are going to fire inflammatory responses in the brain independent of the fact that you have.
Antibodies, this is the statute I grew up causing greater inflammatory response in the brain and hindrance of neural conductivity.
So, that even makes it worse.
So, you want to do those tests.
So, I would not say.
So, somebody called my staff and said, hey, which is first of them.
I want to know if the right machine is going to be really good for Parkinson's.
It's not as simple as that.
We need to dig into this.
I would just go by a right machine for a disease.
You need to get into the nuances of what is what is causing more inflammatory process and more progression of that disease.
And with Parkinson's because it has an autoimmune nature, we know already we need to dig into what are some of the autoimmune triggers.
Dr. Tooth, the horde of our autoimmune chronic disease and autoimmune course, but I go into.
And nausea in detail of that of what I just said on that course.
So, if any of that's far too old, maybe that's what I got courses.
I don't know what is it 75 bucks or something like that by that course start studying watching some of those videos and learning that piece of.
Understanding autoimmune diseases, I have a lot of doctors that actually get on those courses and do that.
So, I think that will be helpful.
So, I would not say, oh, go buy a right for Parkinson's.
We need to do a little bit more in-depth discovery.
If you really want to reduce the progression of Parkinson's, you're not going to cure it.
But you can reduce the progression and you can reduce the flares and reduce the symptoms by finding those triggers.
Because you're going to, when you find those triggers and eliminate those, you're going to reduce the inflammatory process that's going on and that will be a big help.
Oh, we got time for maybe two more questions.
Advice for a 73 year old male just received blood work back.
Shall we D H E S is only five range should be 229 to 284 can supplement it with the H E A B beneficiary for that or necessary for the elderly.
Okay, so D H E A is a horrible that's created in the adrenal glands.
So, the adrenal glands create D H E A.
D H E A is also a intermediate metabolite that then produces testosterone.
So, it is part of your stress hormone system.
It's part of your adrenal hormone system and giving a person D H E A because you can buy D H E A supplementation out there.
And I'm going to tell you why I'm against it.
So, if you supplement with D H E A, you will D H E A because it's a horrible works on a negative feedback loop.
So, if you supplement with D H E A, you will literally turn off production of D H E A.
In this case, you could say, well, this person doesn't have any anyhow.
What's going on?
You have to ask the question, why again?
So, you have to go, why does this person not have any D H E A?
Is the person on testosterone lowered medication?
So, a person on that has prostate cancer that's on endogen deprivation therapy,
that can actually affect D H E A and maybe that's the cause of it.
No, let's pretend that's not the case.
I don't know what the case is here.
So, I don't know who this person is, but let's pretend.
No, they're not on loop run.
They've never taken that.
What else could lower D H E A?
So, first of all, you'd want to test for a complete adrenal profile.
You want to test for cortisol too.
So, if the person has D H E A in the pits like this,
and their cortisol is flatlined, then you know they have complete,
what's called complete adrenal burnout in layman's term.
So, they have complete adrenal fatigue.
So, you need to build up the adrenal glands again, step number one.
But you also want to find out why.
So, there could be the reason why it could be this person has burned the candle
at two ends for a long period of time.
Maybe they're in a very, very stressful relationship.
Maybe they're in a horrible, horrible work environment.
Who knows?
Because you've got to figure out the reason why.
It can't be because they have antibodies to the adrenal gland.
It can be because they have two terry issues.
There's a whole bunch of can be.
So, we've got to figure out the reason why.
If you just use D H E A in this, you have to be careful.
Because, again, not knowing the complete history is a detriment.
Because if the person does have prostate cancer and you give D H E A,
you will actually be stimulating testosterone production,
which may not be what you want in this case.
Again, if they don't have prostate cancer,
I think you should look at testosterone levels also.
So, doing a complete Dutch test, D U T C H,
is really an order to really answer this question.
I'm not a fan of using D H E A as a supplement.
Unless the person is, you know, we cleared all the other things.
And there's things in their life that they cannot change.
For instance, I've had people where they have,
they're in an abusive relationship that is not changeable right now.
And their body is just completely burned out.
And their cortisol levels are flatline in the pit.
And their D H E A is burned out like this.
Then you give D H A for a short period of time,
just to get them over the hump.
But if we really need to look at the complete picture,
or somebody like this, we really should do a case review
and do some further investigation.
It wouldn't be.
I think it's really wrong when practitioners,
when you see, that's why it's wrong to get your advice from Instagram
and Facebook and things.
Because if you don't look at the big picture,
you just, you're basically, again, throwing darts at the wall.
And it can be very dangerous.
I just actually had a conversation with a person this morning
that got was on D H E A from another practitioner.
And I had to explain to them.
This is not that person.
But I had explained to them,
the same thing that you, you're just shut down your D H E A.
And we actually did a Dutch test on that person,
and their D H E A was, was at the bottom of normal.
And it's like, well, how was that when you're taking it?
It's because you're shutting down your adrenals by taking it.
So I'm not a fan of taking exogenous hormones,
unless you absolutely need it.
And let's say your thyroid is just shut down
and you have Hashimoto's and your energy is down.
Well, you're going to have to take an exogenous thyroid.
But then you have to understand that you're going to be on that for life.
And there could be a lot worse things of life than beyond exogenous thyroid.
But why just shut down your adrenals by taking this without figuring out why?
So all right, that's all.
We're going to have time for today.
Thanks for joining us and submit your questions on line
in our, there's multiple places online to submit your questions.
If you're a member of our courses, you can submit it on all our pages,
on every page, on all our courses.
So make sure you do that.
If you're not a member of the course, make sure you get on our courses.
Super cheap, tons of information.
No reason for you to have a better state of health when you look at that.
All right, thanks so much.
Bye-bye.